I think porn should be banned and I
think sex work as they call it of course
should be illegal it's the pragmatist in
me Lila that just thinks if you force
this Ong ground you're going to create
prohibition 2.0 there's upload videos of
young girls rapes and boys rapes on
PornHub all over the place and it takes
sometimes months or years to take it
down because pornhub's legal and there's
all this burden of proof now on the
victim just show that this was me this
was me as a child I didn't consent take
it down
lla I saw this incredible clip of you
doing a debate about relationships
between men and women which is one of
the things we want to talk to you about
uh and uh I have a bit of a reputation
for quote unquote destroying people with
facts and logic and what I love to do is
use the logic that people present in
order to challenge their own argument
and that's what you did with this guy
we'll play a clip of it I might have
multiple family you never know I might
like family more than you so much I have
five do you think that's a good thing to
have have multiple families I think it's
good if there's one dad and there's not
a bunch of stepparents involved and and
the dad can be the hero and those five
families live a 10x better life than
they would have otherwise just man I do
but you don't think that it will be
ultimately a an opportunity for jealousy
or disharmony amongst women or always
going to be jealous what's changed about
that women been jealous all the way
through time I'm not jealous in my
marriage I don't care about your
marriage I'm talking about mine well my
life is going to be so I don't answer to
you and you would want that for your
daughters yeah yeah yeah I I'm I live my
life unapologetically on my terms so but
I guess I'm asking if you're comfortable
answering obviously but are you wanting
to be a role model for your kids is that
part of a th% a father should show up in
every way for his children I think I'll
be better than most fathers regardless
of how many children I have I might have
a hundred but you think part of being a
role model it's okay for your kids not
to know even their your relationship
status with their own mom they will know
their relationships with me and their
mother but you have other relationships
with other women too what does that have
to do with anything but I'm just
wondering if you think I haven't even
said that I'm just saying like if I want
to I will but you don't think that's a
problem for your daughter to know that
about their dad that that he has
multiple mistress that's up to my
daughter man why don't you just commit
to one and choose to be faithful to
her I'm just not wired that way I spent
my whole 20s trying to fix myself
thought something wrong man of self
control you you work out you do business
you can possess your own your own power
and direct it the way you how I am it's
not how I am you think that might be a
limited mindset
I think it's none of your business but I
don't want you to think I'm triggered by
you I'm not okay I saw somebody say that
and I think that's interesting I think
you're annoying but I'm not triggered
you know what I'm saying no you are
you're annoying in like this goodie two
shoes type way and that's fine uh I'm
going to live my life on my terms unap
unapologetically like truly so uh you
can ask me this 85 different ways at the
end of the day I'm going to walk out of
here the same man essentially what what
we're seeing in the world right now is
there's a lot of these influences
who are telling men and women some
moronic things about relationships
between men and women and you expose
that beautifully tell us a little bit
about what your thinking was and and
kind of how you see this whole thing
sure well first of all it's interesting
that the people that I think are some of
these influencers giving moronic as you
call it advice often they themselves
don't seem to come from very happy
situations I think that when you're
referring to the clip the gentleman
there you know he's he says I can't fix
myself like he's basically a victim of
himself in his relationships where he
has to be promiscuous he can't commit to
one woman and he even admitted when I
talked to him that it seems like
something that he doesn't have control
over he's just a slave to his passions
basically and it just does someone want
to live like that you know to be a slave
to your appetites is that really going
to bring happiness in the end and it
seems like you know you look at the
statistics the research on this people
that do not you know people that have
multiple families people that divorce
people have broken relationships all in
all are less satisfied and less happy
according to all the data than people
that are in monogamous long-term
committed relationships and so you look
at just the sheer data and the the the
large body of it that shows what brings
human happiness in relationships and
it's not what those people are preaching
many of them anyways and that in of
itself you know along with just real
world examples you know of people that
my parents have been married 40 plus
years and they've struggled and loved
each other through it and I look at them
as this beautiful example of what I
aspire to in my marriage and that's what
we need to have as models again as
opposed to I think you know the
influencer culture of just do what you
feel and one of the most interesting
things about uh people like that guy and
I don't know him I'm not picking on him
particularly it's a phenomenon we see
across particularly the online world is
a kind of like you know I do feel men
are lost I I do feel that they've been
demonized for quite a long time by
certain elements of the culture and
young men in particular and we have
young men that work for for us and I
listening to their take on what's going
on is quite interesting but one of the
things that is happening is a lot of
young men are being told that you know
you must take control you must and these
are not bad things actually men should
take control of themselves and their
emotions but with what your conversation
with that guy revealed is that it's very
one-sided it's like yeah take control be
in charge go but when it comes to some
other things when it comes to the way
you relate to women when it comes to
what are you doing to build
relationships it's encouraging men to be
completely out of control of the very
things that historically Society has
trained men to be in control of because
that's how Society needs to be for it to
work right it's control over your
economic future you know be disciplined
save money work hard be an entrepreneur
it's control over your physical body to
be healthy and fit and strong but
there's no control over your sexual
appetites which can make or break
someone's future right I mean you look
at the abortion rate you know the fact
that out of abortions today nine out of
10 women having abortions are unmarried
you know these are abortion is happening
because people are having sex outside of
marriage and they're having sex with
lots of different people and they're not
ready to commit and not ready to raise
that child and so you have this abortion
crisis and you know you look at
pornography and porn addictions people
can't be monogamous and stay with one
woman and love one woman and all of that
is because people are not directing
their sexual passion if you can't do
that as a society the society is going
to crumble and the social data data
shows that the thing that I find really
worry lla is you see these some of these
influences and we know all know who
we're we're talking about about naming
names and they put forward this
narrative that it's not just about you
know men being better which I'm all for
but it's about pushing women down like
women are something to be conquered and
dominated over and that is your role as
a man and to me that seems the most
toxic of narratives I think it's a
reaction to modern feminism of course
you know it's this you know women are
now in many ways outperforming men in
you know in corporate jobs they sort of
affirmative action for women so they
more women graduate college today so I
think there's an anger among men who see
women as being given the special status
over them in in the western world and
the reaction of you know ultimately I
think it's a
very it's a wrong reaction but you can
understand the reaction when you look at
modern feminism is training many women
to see men as less than to hate men even
to reject men we don't need men men are
not necessary for our happiness anymore
when I think the the foundation of any
society needs to be a strong family to
raise the future children and children
need a mother and a father who love each
other and have respect with one another
and are married and committed to each
other but that vision is lost for many
people and so you have men now uh
disaffected unhappy broke it feeling
upset with women feeling they can't even
find a woman and there's a lot of I
think uh divisiveness that has entered
into the relationship between men and
women that's becoming more mainstream
today which is again yes a result of
modern feminism but also men are just
struggling they're they're disaffected
they're looking for how do we how do we
root ourselves how do we succeed
economically how do we find
relationships and we are the teachers
for those men then they're attracted to
these online influencers and the online
influencers come in because there is a
father vacuum exactly and that a lot of
these poor boys you know when I I talk
for many years in poor in poor areas of
London a lot of the boys and a lot of
the girls that I taught dads weren't
around you are uh more likely today than
in any other decade to be raised in a
single parent household particularly a
single mother household in the United
States and so the amount of children
being raised without fathers in the home
is unprecedented today and what does
that bring for young women I think it
brings special problems certainly for
all men and women girls and boys it
brings more drug addiction more
incarceration less but worse economic
and uh educational outcomes but it also
brings more likeliness to divorce more
likeliness to cohabitate less likeliness
to marriage in the future for those
children so you're building these cycles
of Brokenness and and you talk about the
cycles of Brokenness um I suppose the
question is particularly the economic
reality that you and Francis were just
discussing which is historic speaking
women want today a cross and up they
want the man to make as much money as
them or more they want and and and be
kind of more successful in some other
ways they want someone to be on their
level or more and yet in a society that
increasingly is you know shaped in a
different way that seems like quite a
difficult problem to
resolve yes I I I I've heard that many
times you know women want the wealthier
man you know the more successful or
powerful man and you know I I look at
and and this is anecdotal yes but I look
at you know women who were raised by
good Fathers you know or maybe they
weren't but they went through work to
really be at peace with men and the
masculine and I think that it's less
about I want a wealthy man or I want a
powerful man and it's more about I want
a good man and I know that that's not a
popular narrative today you know
especially in certain online spaces
where it's like no women are out for
money they're out for security that's
not what I'm saying yeah that's not what
I'm saying I think your point is
accurate in that women will prioritize a
man who's kind and a man who's going to
be a good father and these are all
important things but cross-culturally
all the eviden is that women look for a
man who can provide yes and I'm not
saying they don't want a man who can
provide but I think there is anyways
I've seen a narrative that they want
it's not just enough for him to provide
as you know and work hard it's that they
want him to be this kind of top one%
super wealthy you know super wealthy
super handsome and that's what they want
and I don't think that's most women
certainly that's some women I'm not
saying there aren't women who are you
know gold digging we're in La a lot
we're in La sure but um but I think
there's a lot of you know the people
that I think are seeking Health in their
relationships right and are seeking
health for themselves you know they have
a positive view of the masculine a
positive view of a feminine they want to
build a family they want a faithful
monogamous marriage those people are not
so much looking for you know wealth and
perfect you know physical Perfection and
their partner they're looking for
qualities like trustworthiness
hard work loyalty and that is what we
should be I think celebrating and and
promoting you know and unfortunately
sometimes I think those are underplayed
in more the dynamic of you got to be
rich you know you've got to be uh
successful that's the way you're going
to succeed with women or whatever it is
that's more promoted instead and I think
that's not doing anybody any favors no I
completely agree uh and that narrative
is definitely out there which is women
are all gold digging hor [__] and blah
blah blah that is out there and people
are saying saying that stuff which isn't
true of the vast majority of women and
the feminist narrative is out there that
men are all rapists and toxic so there's
obviously two very negative Nar
narratives about men and women that are
both false yes this is what I always say
any ideology that is designed to drive
men and women apart is bad whether it's
feminism or this red pill stuff or
whatever definitely true however at the
kind of if you go down from the top 1%
the top 1% of gold diggers the top 1% of
super wealthy men at the end you're
still left with a society in which women
increasingly uh graduate from college at
higher rates make more money than men
until they become mothers Etc and that
is still a structural issue that gets in
the way I think you're right that it is
um it certainly it certainly doesn't
help that man who says I want to succeed
and do my best and then he feels he's
being disfavored not because of his
qualities or his work but because of
being male to to that woman next to him
whether it's in the job process
application process or you know applying
to a university and I think that's very
harmful I don't think there should be
sexism uh you know even affirmative
action sexism is sexism in the end in
the University application process in
jobs and I think the bigger Point
underlying that is what are we telling
women what is the message to women about
what your fulfillment as a woman looks
like and because of feminism we have
been instructed and think also
materialism quite frankly materialistic
Western culture that our success is in
how we how how successful we are
materially speaking you know how much
money we make how far we go how many
degrees we get yes education is
wonderful but to what end are you being
educated right are you being educated
for healthier life and your
relationships or so that you can just be
this successful person and women now
instead of being valued for yes you are
a whole person but in society you have
that special gift of being able to bring
life into the world as a woman and that
should be valued and cherished and yes
in put up on a pedestal that we can
bring life and families need special
protections mothers fathers need special
protections and special support in
societies okay so now women encourage
that your your femininity your Womanhood
bringing an ability to be a mother is
worth cherishing worth valuing but
that's not the message at large the
message at large is go be a girl boss
you know the Cheryl Sandberg message of
lean in go sit in the corporate
boardroom that's where you're going to
fulfill your feminine power uh compete
with men in the workplace and I think
that yes no nobody should close off
those doors to women you know they
shouldn't be shut to women but I think
the greatest superpower of a woman that
makes her different from a man is her
ability to be a mother and that's what
we should be celebrating in a society
and we should be fostering what's the
message for women today when it comes to
uh
their ability to Mother largely speaking
your Reproductive Rights I mean think
about that women's rights National
Organization for Women in America one of
the leading Pro women's organizations as
they claim their top plank is not let's
help women be fully mothers and then
also educated and be able to be
fulfilled in their life holistically
let's fight rape let's fight abuse their
top plank is let's have ensure that you
can have an abortion and that it's tax
funded and that it's supported by
society and that there's every
restriction is removed so when women are
told your empowerment is Reproductive
Rights AKA abortion which is killing a
child and typically abortion is
encouraged so that you can go to school
if you're pregnant you can get the job
and not be set back in your career what
is that message to women the very
antithesis of what it means uniquely to
be a woman your ability to mother is
being denigrated and saying that
motherhood ability you have is actually
a threat to you competing with men and a
threat to you being successful there was
this famous um speech at the Golden
Globes just a couple years ago I don't
know if you saw Michelle Williams an
actor and she's clutching her prize her
her her statue and she's thanking the
abortion that she had as a young woman
for the success that she had in her
entertainment career and she's saying if
I hadn't had the right to choose I would
not be on the stage basically holding
this uh holding this prize I mean that's
the image of Womanhood in the western
world you need abortion and you don't
need men in order to be successful and
that's your empowerment it is no wonder
there is so much division between men
and women and so much
unhappiness look what you're saying is
incredibly powerful and the that I'll be
honest with you this is a subject which
I'm still not completely decided over if
I'm being honest but that is absolutely
horrendous and an awful awful thing to
say especially as well when you look at
I'm sorry to interrupt it kind of makes
sense though do you know what like in in
some ways because what you're saying it
it makes sense because if if the purpose
of a woman is to be successful and
compete with men to be better than men
and to be better than men and if what if
what
we if if a baby prevent my wife has a
baby she's not very successful in her
career right now cuz she's with our son
right then
yes then she is right to thank her
abortion for her success if that's the
frame in which we operate the baby is
now the aggressor the the potential
child or the actual child if you're
pregnant with that baby to your success
as a woman to your empowerment and
fulfillment as a woman and so the very
thing that is unique about you from
different from men your ability to our
reproduction systems are different
that's our
primary I mean it is our biological DNA
difference is our reproductive systems
and those systems uniquely different in
how they affect us I can bring a life
into the world through my body it's
amazing I can gestate I can then lactate
that requires commitment of at least N9
months and Beyond and that requires does
society organize itself to prioritize
reproduction and value it or does it
reject it on the alar of economic
success careerism material good and
that's what our society has chosen so
far at large sorry mate no it's it's
fine it's fine um and what that breeds
in women I think is a real sadness
because what they've taught been taught
to believe is that this career will make
you happy and I think what they realize
as they hit mid to late 30s even early
40s is I've kind of been sold
aike I mean women yes absolutely I think
there's a lot of we talked about
disaffected men a lot of disaffected
women who are unhappy who are single who
are childless uh you know if you go on
Reddit and look at sort of the threads
about um fertility and declining
fertility and egg freezing there's these
horror stories of women you know they
lost their fertility window they were
working they were studying so hard uh
they can't find you know a man you know
they're in their late 30s and just the
the abject misery many of them feel that
they their life they feel is passing
them by and there's nothing they can do
about it it's not just women though I
would say both women and men who when
they they wake up one morning and they
realize where am I at you know I'm I'm
I'm not married I have no children and
you know you shouldn't get married and
have children uh just because you know
statistical research tells you it'll be
happier like you have to go into it to
want to serve and love your spouse you
know serve and love your children but
those acts of service and love to
another human being is a purpose bigger
than yourself and if you don't have that
in your intimate life
uh you're going to be unhappy you're
you're going to be a drift people are
made for relationship we're human beings
you know as mammals we're made for
relationship but we have spirits and
we're made for connection if we don't
have that if we just have ourselves and
we're living for ourselves or you know
we have maybe just sexual connection
without the deeper connection we're not
going to be happy and you know the we
talked about data but you I'm sure it's
been mentioned on your show before
everyone seems to mention it we know
about it but the Harvard happiness study
you know this study over a hundred years
two cohorts of men removing you know
economic differences and educational
opportunities removing those to look at
them as the same meaning you have your
less wealthy cohort your more wealthy
and educated Co cohort and they
discovered that at the end of the day
for both groups the happiest healthiest
men were the ones that ended up choosing
long-term marriages and staying married
and you found misery bankruptcy lack of
Health in both groups of men even the
ones that were wealthy and and from good
educational backgrounds versus not and
you found better outcomes for both group
groups of men including the more you
know the poorer group the less educated
group when they married and when they
stayed married and built families
hundred years of research on that and
there's so much other data to that too
again we're made for connection we're
made for long-term committed
relationship do you think and this is
going to me sounding like a big old
Lefty but do you think part of this is
the fact that we live in consumerist
Society where every type of relationship
is transactional now if every type of
relationship is
transactional doesn't that mean that
we're going to view sex as transaction
we're going to view relationships as
Transaction what can I get because that
seems to be the very basis of our
society I think that's a great point I
mean we are you know you can blame some
people like to blame capitalism for it I
would just say it's you can have a
capitalistic Society but still values
that see the human person as more
important than material things or
material success but yeah I think people
today you know we we don't think I mean
I think technology helps you know hurts
this too our connection with each other
um we're always trying to produce
something you know it's always about
production uh producing work product
producing you know likes on the internet
producing success and so we're not in
the present moment with each other and
the the pace of life is so fast there's
not really time to is there even time to
fall in love is there even time to have
a baby take the time off of work to have
the baby take the time off of work to
raise the baby we don't make time for
Human Relationships today the way we
used to and I think media plays a part
because in media what is uh celebrated
is you know success and wealth and
physical Beauty and these things as
opposed to experience of just being with
people because you can't really see that
in media you know you don't you can see
I guess snapshots on Instagram of people
you know having beautiful times with
their family maybe having breakfast but
watching someone else do that is
different than living it yeah and also
as well it's this idealized view that we
have of relationships and we tend to be
a society that avoids discomfort and
every relationship has its ups and its
downs and it's also there are going to
be times where you don't get on that
well and instead of thinking to yourself
right let's move on to the next one
which you're incentivized to do in our
culture
it's about sticking and working in it
it's a great Point yeah if you just run
when it gets hard uh you'll never you'll
never find I think the happiness and the
purpose that you want because life is
going to be hard one way or another you
know even if you choose to live for
yourself live for your career you know
the Michelle Williams hold the golden
statue and have the abortion to succeed
uh there will still be hardship you know
you'll feel loneliness there'll be the
stresses of your work it's what hard do
you choose and you know I love look at
my parents marriage I mentioned that and
I look at the couples that I admire who
stick with each other through difficult
times and work at the relationship it's
not idealized like it's not going to
take work communication takes time your
relationship is not a uh it's not
something of utility it takes some it
takes your time that you can't just plug
in and plug out it's saying You' got to
sometimes it's going to disrupt your
work week sometime it's going to be the
thing that you have to invest
significant time into and do that
regularly and have just Leisure Time
with the person you know just be with
them if you can't if you can't make
space for that in your life and
prioritize it then I don't think you're
going to find the happiness that you
want we'll be back with our guests in a
minute but first do you remember the
Canadian trucker protest in 2022 where
thousands of Canadians came out to
protest covid restrictions and vaccine
mandates now these protests lasted for
weeks and the people out on the streets
needed funds as any Grassroots protest
would so so people set up online
crowdfunding campaigns which raise
millions of dollars incredible but once
a Canadian authorities had started to
criticize the crowdfunding platforms
ramping up pressure to close the
campaigns it didn't take long for the
biggest crowdfunding platform the one
we've all heard of to completely
capitulate and shut the campaigns down
now this is where our partners give send
go come in they stepped in when the
other platforms backed off and raised
millions of dollars for the truckers
when they were criticized and dragged
through the Canadian courts GFS and go
said it respected diverse views and
believed hope and freedom are values
worth fighting for this is why we're
proud to partner with GI and go so if
you need to crowd fund for whatever
means the most to you then don't go to
the big Tech platforms we recommend you
do it on give send go starting a
campaign on give Sendo is easy and
intuitive go to gend go.com today that's
giv send go.com to start raising money
for whatever is important to you and now
back to the
interview and there's also we've started
to be this culture which I find morally
repugnant that celebrates
divorce I've seen like you know divorce
parties divorce cakes and look sometimes
marriages aren't good sometimes you know
there's things like abuse or there's a
breakdown of a relationship but there's
nothing to be celebrated you know that
two of the top reasons for a div divorce
is number one I just wasn't committed
lack of commitment meaning something
else became the priority more than the
relationship which it's easy to do in
today's world your work uh you know your
other Pursuits or feeling of
self-fulfillment outside of the
relationship they're stopping me from
this thing that I want to do um and the
second thing is
pornography because people are you know
pornography is everywhere it's
ubiquitous Everywhere You Look only fans
has just ballooned in the last few years
now like every young girl is thinking
not every but many is this a career
option for me it's like being an
Instagram influencer uh was a few years
ago now it's should I consider an only
fans account you know I've had people on
the internet where are you going to when
are you going to do only fans I mean
it's just like everyone's I mean it's
ridiculous obviously but it's we don't
get that you don't get that but it's
it's every it's just now it's part of
this the the mindset of like women do it
women do it everywhere um you know I've
been on a lot of podcast talking to
different people in the porn industry um
I don't even like to call it that
because it's a sexual exploitation
industry but the amount of sheer porn
use you know porn is the most searched
for thing on the web um child assault
material they say child porn is
increased in its searches every single
year over the last decade it's
incredible and yes it's breaking down
marriages but what else is it doing I
mean it's it's it's polluting male
female relationships more than any other
Force I would say to today and and why
would you say that lla why would you say
that it's polluting male and female
relationship because it's teaching
objectification as the first as the
first glance of how you see someone
instead of seeing someone as a person
holistically I'm going to engage with
you're training yourself to see someone
as a sex object and when you see people
as sex objects certainly you're not
training yourself to be in a healthy
relationship because when you are in AAL
relationship you see someone as a full
person body mind and soul and you care
for them you're willing to sacrifice for
them they're not an object for your
sexual gratification do you think the
point that you've just made and we'll
stick with porn but I I just want to
make a parallel there because you talk
about it teaches
objectification I kind of feel like
social media is basically that for
everything else too where we've become
avatars of ourselves you are the latest
three tweets that You' posted instead of
the fully rounded human being that other
people don't really get to see and so we
are looking at each other in every lens
now through a very tiny sliver of our
personalities very often the one that we
want to portray to the world and we've
kind of become very
superficial not just sexual all our
connections have become quite
superficial as a result I mean it's an
interesting point I think it's certainly
true for I mean especially for
Generations like I think about Jen's ear
you know one one beneath us I think our
our younger brothers and sisters who
just grew up they didn't have a world
like I didn't have an iPhone when I was
13 yeah every gen here did so that's all
that they know and you know they're more
likely to you know text than talk you
know they're more likely to Snapchat
than talk or meet in person and yeah
what does that do to how you see people
at a very deep level it's I'm sure it's
not healthy um pornography is an
additional uh you know unique evil
because you can see someone's twitter or
their Instagram and yeah maybe not see
them fully but you learn about them and
you can have maybe maybe that can
contribute something positive to the
relationship oh you had a new baby you
know oh I learned about what you thought
about this late latest current event
interesting let's engage and have a
coffee about it with
pornography um you're violating yourself
and the other person because you're
using them for sexual gratification when
human beings are not objects for sexual
gratification and you've spoken to a lot
of people in the porn industry you've
been in debates with them what have you
leared about this particular industry H
it's an interesting question um well
first of all Beyond talking to people in
part so because my my pro- lifee is
connected to some of investigative work
I've done on trafficking human
trafficking how that connects with
abortion a lot of trafficking victims
have abortions uh they pressure to have
them by their pimps I mean there's a
whole uh world of abuse and exploitation
that connected here children are I mean
it makes sense if you um abuse sex New
Life comes into the picture inevitably
new human lives because sex brings life
even with contraception it has a failure
rate 50% by the way of um women who have
abortions are using contraception the
month they got pregnant 50% of women
have abortions so you see this
connection between New Life being
destroyed because we exploit people
sexually uh Louise Perry I think she was
on your podcast she's phenomenal she had
a piece out recently uh calling
attention to the fact that under
brothel uh you look at you excavate
brothel from like the Roman Empire and
you're going to find the common thing
that you can find are the bodies of male
infants uh the skeletons of male infants
The Remains because the female infants
can be used for sex trade but the male
infants would just be murdered upon
being born so you find this connection
age-old between infanticide between
abortion and sexual
exploitation um
but all that to say you know when I talk
to people in the porn
industry I think there's certainly a
disconnect between um there certainly
defense of abortion I found that very
common because we need abortion it's our
backup contraception but I also find a
lack of I think just selfworth I mean
that's the most tragic thing is that I
am good for money I am good for money by
selling myself sexually and money is
something that is this uh prize that I
need to pursue in large amounts of money
I'm talking to successful usually you
know people making lots of money and
these material things this car that I
bought the standard of life that I have
is worth it to me to sell my body um and
I find that for some that I talked to
you know single girls involved in uh you
know sexual exploitation and pornography
many of them Express the desire to want
to have a relationship with a man and be
married and even have children one day
and they are sort of torn because they
know what they're doing may prevent that
but what they're doing is so financially
lucrative so they're going to keep doing
it and so I've talked with a lot of only
fans Creator girls who say they want to
be married but they feel like that this
is how they're making money and so they
can't kind of they can't make the
sacrifice today of I'm not I'm going to
reject this profession because it's
going to hurt you know this trade
because it's going to hurt my potential
to be in a in a loving marriage and have
kids one day but it's again this
short-term it NE back to I think even
you know sexual ethics it's preventing
short-term gratification it's saying no
to short-term gratification for
long-term love and in that moment you
see it play out I'm getting money for
this thing that I'm doing right but I
want this long-term thing but I'm not
willing to sacrifice today to get the
long-term thing that I want this is
going to sound very crude you know what
I find interesting and I think it comes
back to what you were talking about
right at the beginning about the idea a
of like women being empowered by taking
control by because and the reason I said
this is going to sound very crude but it
is you know true if we were talking
about other animals a lot of the women
you're talking about are very beautiful
women who could probably secure a
similar material Lifestyle by finding a
partner who is who's very successful
financially and being with them and
having kids as they probably eventually
W so it seems like at least exploring
this with you I'm thinking out loud and
this is always a bad idea on the
internet but we'll try right it's almost
like it's about I want to make the money
here do you see what I'm saying yeah
because they could just marry somebody
who who will make that money because
they're likely to be able to secure
someone who could do that right and it
seems to me like it's not just about
materialism it's also about the IDE what
we call empowerment now which is people
ripping themselves apart from each other
instead of seeking to bond together and
build things together I mean it's a good
it's a good point I mean I think there's
also the an idea there of bodily
autonomy of I have this body I can do
whatever I want with and that's very
much I think we've been infected with
that especially women in this country to
say you have this radical bodily
autonomy to the point that if you're
pregnant you can kill another body
inside your body um and you know the
bodily autonomy argument with
pornography is I can do whatever I want
with my body as long as I'm calling the
shots as long as I'm consenting to even
this degrading sexual act and what's
wrong with that argum I'm not degraded
what's wrong with that argument because
look a kind of the liberal perspective
of which I'm broadly in sympathy with is
people are allowed to do whatever the
hell they want to do within the law
right I mean that that's what the law is
for it's to demarcate what we can do and
what we can't do well all rights have
responsibilities so my right to certain
freedoms will always come with
responsibilities and the law should be
founded on human rights on ideas of
Rights and ideas of responsibilities as
a you know person in this country I have
the right to choose to marry and choose
to have children no one can stop me from
that but then I have the responsibility
in a marriage to my partner certain
responsibilities I think I owe them
loyalty I owe them Fidelity I ow owe
them my kindness my presence and if I
conceive a child and whether I'm married
or not and I conceive a child I have a
responsibility as a parent even if I
didn't consent to the ACT act within my
body of conception happening I consented
to sex having sex and if I conceive a
child I have a responsibility now to
that child even if I don't want it but
the bodily autonomy argument says I have
endless rights with no
responsibility and yes you have an
amount of autonomy to the point where
someone else has rights that you may
have responsib abortion I agree with you
that's a much more complicated thing but
in terms of the sex
industry what is the argument for a
woman who wants to go and have sex for
money yeah to not do that one more thing
before on abortion I just want to say
and then I do want to answer that I
don't think abortion is complicated okay
I think it's actually very simple
because it's a question of is it always
wrong to kill an innocent person an
innocent human is it always wrong to
kill an innocent human and I don't know
would you agree it's always wrong to
kill an innocent human yes okay I think
we can agree and most people do agree I
would say 95% of people I talk to agree
which is nice all right well abortion
ends life of an innocent human and I can
prove that to you you don't need to it's
the pre-born in you know fetus embryo is
a human of course clearly they're alive
abortion is an act that kills them and
they're innocent they committed no wrong
age so therefore abortion because it
kills an innocent human is always wrong
so all the Nuance that we've invented
around abortion all the arguments all
the rationalizations and justifications
fall apart when you look at plainly what
is right and wrong and what that human
life is there are human life so but I
wanted to set that because I I think
abortion it's unpopular to talk about
people don't like to talk about it or if
they do they want to talk about it in
the framework of women's rights and
empowerment they don't want to talk
about what it is that it kills a human
life they don't want to talk about the
morality that that's always wrong we
have no problem talking about it we've
had people from both sides who are as
strident as you are uh so we we I
consider it logical it's it's not an
extreme one way or the other I didn't
say extreme I said
a different thing you're passionate
about it which I completely respect
totally but come back to me with to the
other argument which is about why women
are and aren't allowed to have sex for
money essentially yeah I think it's
because we have a responsibility and
Society at large I think porn should be
banned and I think sex work as they call
it of course should be illegal and first
of all it's because uh sex is designed
to bring life into the world and even
with contraception like I said it often
does and so you need to morality calls
us to have responsibility along with
rights when it has when it comes to sex
and our responsibility with sex is that
we are ready and prepared you know as
ready as we can we no one's fully ready
to be a parent but we are willing to
accept the responsibility of a new life
that we may create and responsibility
would say that we should be having sex
in scenarios in circumstances that are
primed for that life to be able to live
and flourish and that's not a one night
stand that's not a hookup that's not a
porn scene that's a ideally that's a
loving marriage that we've freely chosen
where we can raise those children
together and so when you look at the
morality when you look at the morality
of sex and sexual ethics you know the
purpose of sex what's it designed for
new life and connection between two
people it tells us a lot about how we
should behave and so to your question
about you know why women shouldn't sell
themselves because what is sex designed
for sex is designed for a connection
between you and another person that I
think should be lifelong um it bonds you
emotionally I think it bonds you
spiritually and there's a lot of science
that shows that but it also can bring
life into the world so your your right
to choose to have sex with someone comes
with the responsibility that you're
choosing that in the context of
committing to them and loving them not
just letting them use you or you using
them for a moment of pleasure okay and I
agree with all of that the one thing
that I would like to talk to about the
porn industry before we go on to the
Banning thing because that's where I
think things get a lot more complicated
if I'm honest um is the addiction
element to porn whereby you see a lot of
men just get hooked on this dopamine
cycle where they are constantly going on
to new clip after new clip and you just
see and you when you talk to these men
you just see that they become hooked on
it in the way that it's almost
druglike yeah I mean exactly it's it is
drug likee for a lot of men and and some
women too I mean there's a lot of female
porn users now
increasingly um which is you know
uncommon maybe a decade ago but it's so
everywhere and it's so you know it's so
encouraged even or treated as such a
casual thing that women are encouraged
to explore it too and girls are
encouraged to explore it too but it's
highly addictive and um
that makes it all the more dangerous but
I think it also tells you something
about the nature of sex sex is very
powerful it's very beautiful and if we
keep treating it as cheap as a society
as something you can literally sell for
a subscription of $5 online for your
account your only fans account um we're
going to keep making misery for
ourselves leaving a path of misery for
ourselves okay so let's get into Banning
porn and this is where I think we're
going to have a disagreement because
he's a massive fan I'm a massive fan I
want to watch it every day mate oh gosh
all day every day someone's going to
clip that we're joking we're joking I
believe you're yeah
yeah when it comes to Banning porn this
is the issue there are lots of things in
the world that I disagree with that I
think are damaging but I think Banning
them drives them underground and it just
creates it encourages a black market
where a black market happens that's
where you have criminal gangs start to
operate because you're not
allowing reputable or the free market to
get involved and you create something
that is far far darker and more
dangerous for everybody involved what
say you to that you can certainly make
that argument about many things like you
know sexual assault material I mean
that's certainly Black Market because
thankfully that's still illegal right
but just because something uh there may
be a black market for something uh if it
were to be made illegal then therefore
it should be made legal I don't think is
a compelling case but hang on a second
most men wouldn't be interested in
sexual assault material but I would say
most men would enjoy I don't know that
that's true some of the most highly
maybe not child sexual assault material
very young children but some of the most
highly viewed pornography like on
PornHub is of you know um mock rape
scenes of maybe just barely of AG girls
inconvenient well I don't know about the
so it's a definitely a very popular some
of the most popular pornography um
especially for addicts that need to get
more and more intense pornography is
violent pornography
well interestingly the statistics show
that it's actually more women that are
interested in that type of content than
men for reasons that historically make
statistic have you seen for that um I I
don't remember where I mean because I've
seen that men it's a it's a highly
popular porn pornography for men maybe
for women too but those two things are
not mutually EX exclusive something can
be very popular with men and more
popular with women for reasons that from
a evolutionary perspective would make
sense to me uh given how human beings
have evolved in the nature of war in our
past and so on right I hear you yeah but
I think the the point I'm making still
stands that um when you're dealing with
something highly addictive and in order
for it to be continually sort of
satisfactory for the addict it needs to
be more and more intense you see more
and more violent and depraved and
degrading
pornography okay um and I take your
argument but surely we can use that
argument for alcohol where I come from
in the UK we have a horrible horrible
relationship with alcohol you know you
look at the destruction it causes the
assaults the
murders deaths when people get behind
the wheel and they're drunk assaults all
of these things and you can use the same
addiction people there's a lot of
alcohol addicts in my country a lot of
people with alcohol addiction I think
the there is um porn I believe is
intrinsically evil uh having a glass of
wine you know not drinking to excess uh
can be a a good even you know it's a it
can be a beautiful thing to do in a you
know at a wedding or on a date or you
know whatever it might be so I think
there's a fundamental difference between
the thing um you know porn on porn and
alcohol I don't think there's a way to
do good porn there's not a way to um
sexually objectify someone in a good way
or to be actually objectified in a good
way but do you think by making it
illegal it's it's then going to drive it
underground and you're going to make
that industry
worse I don't think it has to be that
way I think in fact if we make it
illegal you know laws have a power to
instruct you know a few decades ago
people didn't wear seat belts and no one
thought twice about it uh then it became
the law to wear a seat belt and there
were campaigns explaining you should
wear seat belts and now you kind of feel
comfortable if you're forgetting your
seat Bel on because you're feeling like
you're you you're certainly the seat
belt for your child it's like oh you
know God forbid and so I do think the
law um is instructive and and and that's
one of its powers and so for us to say
yeah sexually objectifying someone um
looking at pictures of someone to you
know have a sexual experience is is not
just immoral but you shouldn't be able
to do that if you're you know on the
website on the web searching it's
illegal to have to create these images
and be putting them up there um and you
know I think it might be a step too far
to Born to ban people who look at it you
know CU that would be very hard to how
would you practically um actually make
that law enforced right it's very hard
to enforce but certainly pornographers
who are profiting off of this um I think
who are exploiting people I think I
don't think that should be legal the
problem with that argument lla and I'm
not unsympathetic to it genuinely is
that the seat belt analogy is not a good
one
because the sexual drive particularly in
men but I mean we evolved to reproduce
right so the sexual driving men in
particular is so strong that no one is
addict no one no one evolved to not wear
a seat belt right so you're going to
have men seeking out sexual experiences
in any which way they can I mean I I
promise you I was a teenage boy once you
know
that there's been lots of Comedy
routines about men uh and how they think
about these things that that thing is
going to drive men it's the it's it's
what drives human beings um so they're
going to seek that out and when we look
at things like Prohibition in this
country over something far less
addictive and far less important to
people as alcohol that does not end well
I think is the point that Francis is
making I I understand the point but I
think to say the answer to you know a
teenage boy having a strong sex drive is
that we should permit pornographers to
have prolific amounts of porn online and
that should be perfectly legal I I don't
think is a sound argument I think it
shouldn't be legal for pornographers to
be Plastering pornography all over the
Internet for teen boys to stumble upon
and then ultimately many of them enter a
cycle of addiction and unhappiness you
know it's not making their relationships
stronger these boys it's not making them
better workers it's not making them
better people um does that mean that
some men won't go out of their way to
find porn that's been illegally created
well of course you know some men who
have such you know maybe a Brokenness
and you know such an intense overriding
sex drive might commit horrible acts
like rape but of course we Don't
Legalize rape you know we say it's
always wrong we're going to stop it do
some bad things still happen yes but I
don't think the fact that the bad thing
may happen still is a reason to continue
to support it economically as a society
allow an industry it's a multibillion
dollar industry uh to allow it to just
operate without any uh any any Force
stopping it I think the reason and we're
pushing back in a kind of devil we're
exploring the argument what we do with
all of our guests you're it's a good
trigonometry conversation I feel that
and as you I mentioned before we started
we recently had auron who's from the sex
industry so we want to explore every
issue from different angles with people
and challenge what they're saying one of
the issues that I think the reason we
having this disagreement if if it is a
disagreement is we're talking about the
practicality you were talking about from
morality and this is my experience of
people who are conservative generally
they have a very strong moral core and
their sense of moral outrage about
things that they find
offensive sometimes overrides the
Practical reality of things I mean for
example the War on Drugs in my
experience doesn't work and causes a lot
of harm a lot of harm does that mean you
know I've got a 16-year-old 16-month son
that you does that mean I want him to be
you know smoking weed when he's 12 no
but would you make the harder drugs
illegal legal excuse me which ones
cocaine would should a cocaine be legal
heroin not for me no so you're you are
for I think but the point here is you
are for some restrictions some
restriction and so you know back to back
to pornography for a moment
um again I agree with you that some
people will look at pornography but I
don't think it's a good argument to say
that because some people will still look
at pornography we should allow because
what I'm advocating for is Banning
pornographers from creating ban only
fans you know ban you know John stano I
I remember him coming to my classroom at
UCLA as a student talking about how
proud he was to be a pornographer and
you know my free speech Professor who
was really into porn it was kind of
gross but he was so excited to have this
famous pornographer and John was saying
yeah the Supreme Court you know is
stopping basically child porn makers but
they still allow me and I was just like
why do they allow you to do what you're
doing it's disgusting
that should be illegal you know looking
at porn I'm not saying that that should
be illegal I think that's impossible to
enforce I agree with you but people
creating it profiting from it I don't
think there's any what about a couple
that Mak their own webcam videos I don't
I don't think any individual or couple
or corporate structure should be allowed
to be making pornography and profiting
off of it where I'm in agreement with
you lla actually is I think that every
single one of those websites should have
should not allow anyone who is under the
age of 18 to view that content and I
think that they that needs to be very
strictly enforced how well there needs
to be I mean I'm not one of these tech
people I know I look like one but I'm
really
not but there needs to be some kind of
child lock and look you know they need
to do everything in their power to make
sure that the people accessing that
content are over the age of 18 but think
about it this way if you are a if you're
PornHub and this is happening right now
yeah pornhub's making billions of
dollars I think PornHub is disgusting
can I just but there but there's that's
who we're talking about I'm talking
about ban the pornographers PornHub is
Case in point right PornHub should not
be por PornHub are not pornographers
they're a platform where people can
share I consider that a pornographer I
mean they're they're publishing you also
want to ban the couple making their own
videos so it's not just that you want to
ban porn you want to B pornography I
want to ban people that create and
distribute pornography yes I want that
that whole system right and porn PornHub
is essential today to that system and
PornHub uh has surprisingly you know
it's not a surprise uh is very um you
know slow reticent about strong controls
of underage viewers of their product
right because you know they they want it
they want that market and they're also
very reticent to have any sort of
meaningful system to stop underage
pornography from being uploaded to to
their you know child sexual assault
material ultimately from being uploaded
to their site but we are still allowing
them to operate with impunity so you
have this additional Problem by allowing
pornography to be published and created
that you always along the along the
edges have it's not just you know a
consenting couple happily making
pornography in their bedroom you know
this sort of myth of that you have young
girls young boys who are sexually
exploited many of who were sexually
exploited from a very young age who are
now part of a system of pornography by
people who are exploiting them and now
they're part of pornography on PornHub
you know there's upload videos of young
girls rapes and boys rapes on PornHub
all over the place and it takes
sometimes months or years to take it
down because porn's legal pornh hub's
legal and there's all this burden of
proof now on the victim to show that
this was me this was me as a child I
didn't consent take it down if the whole
system wasn't allowed to exist in the
first place you're protecting so many
victims I this is the other side that
needs to be talked about protecting so
many potential victims you see I'm in
look I think a lot of what you're saying
I really do agree with I think that the
whole child exploitation when it comes
to sex is abhorent it's vile and if what
you're saying is true and you're not the
first person I've heard saying this
about PornHub they need to be
investigated and if they are not doing
everything in their power to protect
children then quite frankly they need to
be shut down because that is vile it's
vile the my issue is with your argument
and I'm somebody by the way who
installed a porn Blocker on their phone
I don't watch it because I think it's
toxic and it's it's bad it's bad my
issue is is not the morality of it which
I'm in agreement with you actually if
I'm being brutally honest it's the
pragmatist in me Lila that just thinks
if you force this underground you're
going to create prohibition 2.0 we saw
what happened when they banned alcohol
you had the rise of Al Capone Etc the
organized gangs I I just think as
unpleasant as it is we need to be
pragmatic regulate it as stringently as
possible block kids from using it and
accept unfortunately that it's here to
stay that is my position yeah I I just I
don't buy the argument that you can
successfully regulate exploitation
material of adults or minors and that
there's a way to do it in a pragmatic or
certainly moral way and I think that
it's all bad it's all proven toxic to
the user it's all harmful to the Creator
um you know it's all often includes you
know really abusive corporations like
PornHub that are immoral all the way
through and so allowing them any sort of
breathing room in everyday Society you
know and economic power by saying you
can operate you can operate just just
make sure the minor there's no miners
just make sure you know you're using you
know an ID or whatever it is um it's
it's not going to be enough first of all
and then second of all the problem isn't
just that minors are exploited it's that
that that adults are exploited too and
exploiting other adults so I I think yes
of course there will be some people who
will still look at porn there will be
some people who still create porn but
they will have much less power and I
think they will make much less money and
it will be much less socially acceptable
than it is
today I was going to move on but I've
just remembered something um from um a
former guest of ours she's an
evolutionary psychologist called Danna
fman um one of the things that I
remember her talking about is and this
is very I mean I say I was going to say
it's counterintuitive but maybe it isn't
societies that allow porn have lower
levels of sexual violence which yeah I'm
curi I would I'd want to see her data on
that and where she got that data yeah uh
I'm pretty sure she's someone who rese
searches these things and she's a very
smart person and not ideological about
it um that kind of makes sense to me
because the pent up frustrations of men
who don't have access to sex of whom as
we discussed earlier there are many many
many I I I can see how those would spill
out in in nasty ways in many ways we're
seeing it now I mean in cells and some
of the things that they have been
involved with with well incels have
access to endless porn yes so I I I I I
think I I would want to see her research
I don't buy it um the research I've seen
actually and the and the studies I've
seen actually prove opposite okay that
the more you train yourself to sexually
objectify someone um the more difficult
it is for you to interact healthfully
with people in real life and I think it
logically makes sense on a logical level
it certainly makes sense from the
stories of those who are porn addicted
that they struggle in their real
relationships it makes sense from the
countless stories of people especially
girls in relationships with uh men or
boys that are you know young these are
teen relationships some of them are
older but who are porn uh trained to
think about sex in terms of pornography
and so they're asked to do degrading
strange acts they're compared to these
ideas that the their partner has in
their head from their porn experience
and exposure so I think uh I I would
have to look at what she's actually
referring to but look at American
society today we have more porn than
we've ever had you know porn is at an
all-time high do we think we're
healthier sexually because of
it you think there's less rape today
than 50 years ago um is there not is
there I'm asking do is there less I
don't know but I I mean I don't think I
I don't imagine that uh I mean there has
been a lot of uhan the concept of sexual
assault has evolved over time which has
been a good thing because in the past
men have been able to get away with
things they shouldn't have been able to
get away with I do wonder whether we
have more sexual violence in our society
I suspect not than than 50 or 100 years
ago I mean I'm I I'll be honest I didn't
come here saying in 1950 this study was
done on rape and we know how much how
much happened um I mean looking at it
from my anecdotal position and I don't
know that that research exists by the
way that we we have those sort of
surveys or how we would have that data
and sorry just to pause there I'm not
sure about in the US but I certainly
until horrifically late on there was
marital rape was legal in the UK I'm not
sure what when the year was but it it
wasn't it was comparatively late so
that's what I meant when I was talking
about the evolu I don't think it's a
it's logical to say you know we somehow
are stopping marital rape by allowing
ubiquitous porn I don't think it it
makes sense there yeah yeah I don't
think that's what we're saying uh anyway
okay well I think I ultimately the
argument of your other guest I would
disagree with i' want to see her data
the data and and sort of the you know
the study I've seen on this shows
opposite that the more you allow sexual
objectification of other people
especially in to an addictive degree um
the more you're going to see at minimum
sexual dysfunction and at maximum sexual
abuse it's been great to have this
conversation about this I know I mean it
it's been great for us coming off as uh
porn Advocates and Defenders uh on the
internet you know this is what we tried
to do with all of these contentious
issues it is just to go let's poke here
let's prod there let's find out what's
going on here and we talk to people from
every position in order to kind of start
to get to the truth so I really
appreciate you kind of playing along and
and giving us your strong views on it
and and then people will come away from
it thinking whatever they think in the
last uh few minutes before we wrap up
and move on to our questions from our
audience uh I wanted to think a little
bit more positively about relations
between men and women and the stuff that
we started out talking about which is is
um one of the things that I uh my wife
was saying to me she was like you really
sound very conservative every time you
talk about family and I was like a
that's true B what the
hell liberals have
families liberals have kids well
interestingly it's many I think it's the
wealthier more educated uh even
identifying as liberal that operate by
what you could call conservative values
they get married many don't even
cohabitate before marriage they get
married they stay married they have
children so you know what's cons what's
called conservative values today are
basically healthy you know values of
monogamy Fidelity family life things
that should not belong to one political
group that's my point which is like how
the hell did this idea come about the
family having kids staying together
working through difficult things as you
were saying in a relationship which
every couple has to do why did that
become a a political issue and then why
did it become a one-side issue well it's
because you see much more defense on the
left of things like
polyamory of things that are sexually
deviant that have been historically seen
as very sexually deviant of things like
um you know cohabitation or you know
marriage is not marriage is just a piece
of paper marriage is not really um the
sacred bond that requires life lifelong
commitment so you see I think you know
from the political side you see
politically speaking more of that
language more of those ideas on the left
despite some of those very people
espousing those ideas themselves being
married and monogamous and all these
things it's like they're saying other
people should experiment with polyamory
you know other children should have
three dads and no mother you know other
other families can have be modern and
operate this way but mine is going to be
more traditional this is my private
Choice over here and it's working for me
but other people surely it will work to
go a different path and I think that
just shows um you know a superiority
complex that is you know harmful they're
kind of exporting harmful ideas for
others while secretly living the
Traditions themselves there's a guy
called Rob Henderson who we've had on
the show I don't know if you're familiar
with him he's he came up with a concept
of luxury beliefs yes um and this is
what you're talking about the people who
vote left and live right essentially
yeah so how do we move forward in the
society that we are in because for me
Louise and I have this conversation
often she's like if I was a billionaire
what I would do is I would pay families
to post wholesome content of them having
breakfast with their little kids around
the table and actually until Nikolai got
to an age where he was starting you got
to a point where you could recognize him
in the street I used to PO post stuff
with me and him all the time because I
want people to see what it's like to
have you to have that to have the joy
that you and I have as parents you know
it's amazing um what can we do to to
break the cycle because the cycle is bad
I don't like where we are as a society
and the fact that it's become a
political football that's crazy to me
yeah that's crazy I agree it's crazy I
like her idea you know encourage people
to post positive pictures even more
meaningfully though I would say we
should encourage people to get married
and stay married because it's hard to
have that happy life with your child
when you're a single mom struggling or
you're a single dad struggling or
whatever it is you know you're the
children fare best and people fare best
in lifelong committed marriages they're
economically better off their uh health
is better the children's outcomes are
better on on every level you know in
every category so how do we as a society
encourage marriage well first of all we
can't constantly Define it away it out
of existence marriage is whatever two
three four consenting results want it to
be marriage is one man and one woman who
can bring life into the world you know I
mean they may not be able to in the end
but that's the design of how life brings
into the world takes a father and takes
a mother and that's the optimal uh way
for a child to be raised who are
committed to each other publicly for
life and that's what we should be
celebrating I think you know public
policy we could do you know cash
benefits for married couples who have
kids you know give them give them money
to encourage you know not just a tax
benefit a tax credit but you you should
get you know there are some policies
actually right now about giving actual
you know cash payments to families that
have kids um and I think that could be a
you got a billion bucks billion dollars
that could be a positive way to
encourage them to um to build up
families yeah I I love what Dolly Parton
does where if she's got a foundation
where if you sign up and you've got a
kid I think under the age of uh nine
then she will send you a book a
month yeah for so you can read with your
kid completely free completely free
which to me what a beautiful thing the
other thing I think we need to do is um
ban abortion it's kind of a no it's a
no-brainer I mean don't kill innocent
people these are children uh when roie
Wade was overruled and some of these
states had trigger laws to enact
abortion bans right now that's being all
contested it's a big fight but there
were all of these um people complaining
online about how now this is going to
change my habits you know now now if I
can't access abortion maybe I'm not
going to sleep with the guy on the first
date or maybe I'm uh you know not going
to um see you know sex as something as
casual basically I I might get pregnant
and I might not be able to have an
abortion now this is a big
responsibility I'll have so abortion has
always been the back door contraceptive
in our society that's how it's used
eliminate that and say you can't kill
children and you can't have this back
door contraceptive we need to change our
sexual behavior if we can change our
sexual behavior uh to see other people
with respect instead of a sexual object
to put sex back into lifelong committed
relationship into marriage you know not
make premarital sex normal or glorified
you know friends is making it fun and
glamorized you know in a TV show you
know cut that cut that out and instead
say sex is amazing it's designed for
Lifelong Love let's celebrate that
instead you're going to do a lot for
male female relationships to be
healthier and you're going to make
marriage and
families Stronger by by many many many
degrees all right well as you know a
last question is always the same which
is what's the one thing we're not
talking about that we should be as a
society and you can't say abortion
because we've talked about it quite a
lot now yeah um we talked about some
very important things what's I mean one
thing we didn't talk about it is talked
about so I'm not going to say it's not
being talked about at all today but the
role of I think having a purpose outside
of yourself particularly a faith
the couples that stay married the
longest the couples that um you know
have the lowest rates of divorce are
couples that have that purpose outside
of themselves they many of them are
they're practicing their their religious
devotion you know they're practicing a
faith they're going to you know church
or they're going to a religious service
once a week they're doing that as part
of a family life there there's something
bigger holding them together than just a
promise they made to each other it's a
there's a promise they made to God and I
do think that you know we kind of tend
to say there's secular over here and
there's religious over here let's keep
them apart when really I think we're
made to be religious as human beings
we're made to be you can say spiritual
if you don't like the word religious
we're made to have want to have a
connection with our creator and so I
think we should
be we should be remembering that the way
that that happens best according to the
data according to you know the research
is when we recognize that there is a
third party in a marriage that it's not
just a commitment and promise I made to
someone else but that this is before God
and of course the community and that we
need both God and the community for a
strong marriage perfect so much head on
over to locals where we ask your
questions and continue the
conversation yeah what's not being
talked about enough is that
contraception is bad what do we talking
about here we're talking about condoms
the coil the pill we're talking about
all of it condoms all of it yeah okay
because any kind
[Music]
of